yet another film I get a lot of people
talking about it when first came out and
then just sort of disappeared The
Rocketeer is superhero of the 40s that
finds a rocket pack and is using it to
try and stop Nazis well okay it's a
little better than I'm making it sound
the more appropriate way to talk about
is Cliff is our hero and he discovers a
rocket pack that was hidden in his place
him his friend played by Alan Arkin test
it out and it turns out they really
enjoy it and they wanna keep trying it
but when the pilot loses control of his
plane it's up to him to save the day and
sure enough now they got a hero on their
hands but evil villain played by Timothy
Dalton is an actor in Hollywood who's
actually a spy for the Nazis they want
to use the rocket pack to take over the
world by flying around and being
unstoppable yeah not the most probable
weapon of war but yeah it's fantasy
things get worse when they kidnapped his
girlfriend Jenny played by Jennifer
Connelly and of course he has to go to
take down an entire army giant monster
thugs and a huge blimp in order to save
her the film definitely has a feel of
the 40s which i think is kind of
welcomed the same guy directed this also
directed Captain America and it shows
they both sort of have the same feel to
them even the hero is kind of similar
and speaking of people in this movie
this one has a lot of big names they
were not yet big names but one of the
reasons I really like this film is that
while you're watching it you're saying
to yourself these people should be big
names because they're all wonderful
performers and they do a great job or
training these parts the only one that
never went on to anything was The
Rocketeer himself and I feel kind of bad
I thought actually he was a pretty legit
Lee I don't know me the part just wasn't
written complex enough for him to shine
but I thought he actually did okay the
effects probably use a little too much
of the green screen technology but
there's still lots of scenes of him
flying around a zone - is there a lot of
action in terms of punching and firing
guns and stuff not really until the end
most of its just watching him fly around
but like I said these characters are
really likable and they're sort of a
good mystery to it as well it has a lot
of dark gritty moments but it has a lot
of light-hearted fun also I get the
feeling this film was sort of trying to
be a more kid-friendly Indiana Jones and
yeah
kind of wait you get like I said there
are still one or two gruesome deaths in
there but nothing along the lines of
Harrison Ford territory
my guess is maybe that's why it didn't
quite catch on I think people probably
did want to see him punch out a few more
people or see a little bit more of a
badass but I don't know for a basic
action-adventure I think it's fine
it's creative it's funny it's got its
dark elements it's got a fun villain
it's got some fun side characters I
don't think it's grand but I think it's
good I don't know if something like
Captain America can be released to do
okay I think this one should get the
same treatment so go check it out and
make its popularity soar again
you